guys thanks for coming back to the
channel we're here in san antonio texas
today we're gonna be building a mortar
pit and filming a video with these guys
and a bunch of other people
but none of that matters because jan and
nick have decided that they were gonna
engage in a game called who can get the
most tick tock followers in four days a
spiritual journey a creative journey
he's just over there like shaking his
head
what originally started as come on nick
come here don't go he's running away
already tell the story we brought our
one wheels here to texas to texas yeah i
mean we're one wheel boys obviously we
had to go out on a ride last night just
explore the the terrain and perhaps find
some whiskey thing about onewheels is
their batteries die deep in the suburban
sprawl of texas our one wheels were on
the verge of death uh an orange glow
cracked through the the monotony of the
evening and there
appeared to us
hooters do you think they have an outlet
i know they do
the sign was lit so we knew they had
electricity right we knew they had
electricity so we went in found an
outlet started enjoying a few uh baby
that's the hostess came over and wanted
to ride our one wheels and said it would
be great for her tick tock with our
hostess flexing on us like that we got
talking about tick-tock and a handshake
was made i'm not entirely sure what
tick-tock is so i tell you guys i think
your best bet is to make some kind of
viral dance just say let's mix the wheel
in yeah like yeah we can do it
it's just a lot of this and great going
oh actually no he's pretty much got it
that's about it real talk we're gonna
build a set here i'm just gonna clean
this whole range i'll do this area first
i'll see how long it takes me i've used
plenty of mechanical equipment before
large trucks hauling giant generators to
sets but i've never actually sat down
stepped in or tried to operate one of
these so we're going to figure that out
right now hey guys welcome to a new
section here on the quarter crew channel
called man vs bobcat where you take a
middle 30s aged man and we see if he can
figure out how to operate a bobcat in
under 10 minutes so first things first
you got a door
um let's see here lights oh it's kind of
reverse on it what do they need me for
it's got rabbit speed that's good
parking brake all right so the first
thing you want to find is uh
where's the off switch in case it goes
in the direction that i don't want it to
go you want to be able to turn it off um
there's a key that's good oh that's off
what do you know i assume that these
operate not only your direction but also
the lift on the bucket so oh it's even
got a diagram here
yeah
oh here we go
is there not a do you see a button pad
there's a code to start it i guess
there's some there's some kind of button
pad i'm looking for
that's the horn that's it that might be
the code too maybe you have to honk the
horn in a certain pattern
i don't think that's how you do it
no
we're gonna be so much more cute than we
are right now at 1 42 i've just made my
tick tock account at tic laurent zero
followers that's good that's really good
dan do you know what you what you're
gonna do no rando jando rando janda oh
man yeah you should do magic dude for
the kids is that it might be for the
kids i might be random for the kids this
might have stumped jake no hey i refuse
to ask anyone else
i'm gonna figure it out
so how this
do you input one one this is our b story
happening i'm gonna get you boys ticking
and talking you're going to make up a
dance too yeah it can't be that hard to
make of a dance
this can't be that hard
oh wait is it just a joke i think
they might it might be a joke
with me yeah then like bobcats don't
don't need
you can just turn them on
well go back yeah let's try it yeah
[Music]
that's right exactly yeah dude matt you
are the secret the dr dre of tick-tock
you know
so reports
they won't start unless the carnival
ride uh arms are down
it's just this one oh
there's first step
so now just turn the key
so carnival ride
got it
all right i'm gonna figure out the rest
i'm not proud that i had to ask for help
to figure out how to start it but i mean
you would have been here all day i've
been here all day
[Music]
yeah there it is
that's right
that's right buddy
just incredibly exciting
[Music]
so it looks like jake mastered the cat
now it's just up to us to master
social media
okay i gotta do this my mother would not
be proud of me right now lower them just
a little bit action
[Music]
that's the one yeah
i'd like to give you my first talk
[Music]
you're already off to a poor start
dude the drake shake introducing the one
wheel drake [ __ ] the one wheel drake
shake funny
pulling back the curtain by myself and
posting
guys turn that camera off we have work
to do
so we need to bring the bobcat over and
do like a little rim and then we're
going to fill up sandbags and stack
those on top from here we're going to
lay like horseshoe mortar placements
we're going to do three of them
just one of these
classic
and then we're gonna bring down the
humvee and set up uh the humvee in the
background with like some camo nets and
stuff fill out the background
i'm not happy about it
we need trash bags and tape because
we're going to build a janky rain rig so
that our uh cameras don't go down
mid-shoot cheap tech to protect some not
so cheap tech there we go there there it
is
it's so wet it's so wet dude look at
this rain jacket that i brought it's
just literal rain
looks good we were delayed by the rain a
little bit but uh we're still on
schedule we'll probably start down on
the ground uh we'll have like team three
run by so there's boots in the
foreground then we'll come up to close
up on evan evan you'll basically turn
yell to the forward observer how we
doing
do you like my
historically accurate binoculars
as we come to a wide and we see
everything that's happening each team is
just loading and shooting mortar rounds
unfortunately this is a nice quick scene
we get a couple nice wides get a couple
power shots a couple mediums a couple
inserts and then we're done i'm going to
grab
yeah i was just trying to get in that
bts you know with these awesome binos
yeah yeah dude action truck hit boys
five four five five four five five four
five
cutting
what are you even wearing
world war ii costumes it's called a
product launch heather yeah we don't
have to do any of this you can get it
anywhere
it's marketing it's dumb we are just
about to finish all of our live action
stuff and then we are done here for
today so tomorrow we are going to
capture where all the mortars land
[Music]
oh there's my shoe
[Music]
the next morning this is the next
morning after we both posted two tick
tocks uh i'm on three oh three i'm on
three three tick tocks i got in some one
wheel yoga oh yeah we're seeing the
numbers right now let's see i got a i
got a dm i got a uh a follower who
appears to not be following me anymore
my guy's got 183 views that's all
natural how can you tell the views no
well i have 399
368
379 and i have three followers
he seems like he's a little bit more
relevant in general right now i mean i
have a comment very nice thank you for
sharing that's what we call fan
engagement and it's a sign that you're
doing something right
my strategy is just look at popular tick
tocks and then kind of try to like add
my own spin to them stand right there
stand right there we're going to switch
clothes ready switching clothes we're
going to literally switch clothes what
is happening just go with it man nick
what are you doing
what are you doing
[Music]
jake
what
huh jake
my my strategy it mostly involves beer
[Laughter]
with the coronavirus spreading in the
u.s there are growing concerns about
potential shortages of life-saving drugs
and medical equipment and now a
startling warning shaking the region of
10 million people
guys we are back from texas and as you
can see we are all in self-isolation but
that is not going to stop us from doing
the final judgment on this tick tock
challenge now it's not just about how
many followers you got okay this contest
is really about the embodiment of what
is a true talker and we will decide who
is the truest talker of them all and
after that for the rules of the
challenge you will both instantly delete
your tick tock profiles let's kick it
off first and foremost with mr laurent
now nick the uh flip the switch with the
drake song
we've seen quite a few of these i think
uh definitely some bonus points on
originality on a already widely known
trend couldn't have done it without you
jake uh i'm not just picking it because
i was in it dan i gotta commend you i
mean the work that you did on the heb
having a good time having a good time
why
we also cannot forget the famous now
infamous drake shake
oh jesus oh god i think this can go
beyond talk you know this can go
wherever i want it to you really taking
this this to heart jen now now on these
notes the winner truest of the talkers
goes to mr nicklerock
indeed indeed
should i be happy about this
i mean what did you learn it's more than
just dancing and yoga girls i learned
that much i think i learned a lot about
life now that this is done uh why don't
you guys each take the moment and delete
your accounts for the camera yeah
congratulations i know you guys are
excited to get these apps off your phone
china's already probably stolen all my
data but it's okay certainly almost
certainly delete account right there
nicely done nailing the coffin
delay
weight off your shoulders hi jen i
showed it to you i did it real quick
yeah dad you have to do it for the
camera no
jen the contest is over you have nothing
else to prove whoa
he just disappeared jen just posted
another talk he just posted one
all right there he is hopefully tell me
what the hell is going on
[Music]
seat belt
no one's heard from jan in four days and
the only information we have on him is
from what he's been posting on tick-tock
i've been contacting his friends
nobody's heard or seen from him but i
was just checking the nest cam this
morning and it looks like jan has been
at the studio for about 12 hours if i've
learned anything from watching his tick
tocks over the last four days he's gone
more and more crazy with each passing
day and he looks like some kind of feral
animal or something like that and i'm
concerned for him not just for his
health but for his mental state as well
okay stay stay at least six females
zoom in so it's fine jan's already crazy
enough when it's not crazy i mean this
is a whole different level
where jake let's drop this through your
head
jan
do you see me
it's okay it's okay man you're not
having a good time we're here no we're
having a great time is your name still
jan
where are you going jim yeah
jay come here hey jake keep your
distance just give us the phone
no one's gonna get hurt okay
six feet six feet retreat retreat
close the door oh god oh jesus
look there's the phone we gotta get that
phone from him the phone seems to be the
source
of all of this if we can get his phone
away from him he'll probably come too
we're going to use your phone as bait
you put tick-tock on it we'll slide it
to him and then whenever he comes out to
get the phone bonk him over the head
with this and then we could steal his
phone we got a friend to save
god
i've become a god
it's nick's account jen take lauren's
account
take clara
you have to get rid of your phone before
you can use this tick tock account
don't tell him i know you're still in
there jan
just take this phone
and let me have that phone
hey
i could be tick
laurent that's a good jim
that's good jake
get the phone get the phone
[Music]
jen
it's me it's dean
where did all my body hair go
how did we get back to the studio this
isn't
texas just sit down i'll explain
everything i promise everything's gonna
be okay
there's been a global pandemic
i'm just glad you're feeling better be
safe traveling home and again we'll give
you your phone back probably and
well don't worry about that for now i
need to ride this board and
i'll be back to work when this
pandemic's over yeah i'll find i'll find
my way i'll find my way be well god
bless godspeed
where's pants
[Music]
what you doing boy